26 millions c'est le déficit affiché
pour le budget primitif 2010 9 de la
ville de fort de france
encore une fois la ville ne vote pas son
budget en équilibre
celui ci sera vraisemblablement
transféré à la chambre régionale des
comptes
l'opposition compare la situation
financière de fort de france un
véritable chemin de croix
il y a beaucoup d'opacité dans
l'établissement du début du budget 2018
donc un déficit de 55 8 millions d'euros
donc la ville a été placée sous tutelle
préfectorale qui a pris un arrêté qui
l'a obligé à intégrer ses déficits
dans le compte administratif qui
continue à avoir un déficit de 22
millions et 20 ans on nous propose un
budget de faillite 2019 cette situation
réduit la marge de manoeuvre de la ville
qui selon l'opposition sera contrainte
d'arrêter un certain nombre de travaux
ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui c'est le
résultat de deux politiques des pilotes
qui mène le la ville et béat à l'arrêt
c'est à dire que c'est difficile
maintenant pour la vie d'autres prônent
des actions d'autres pontes des
chantiers et de mettre justement cette
ville en activité c'est ce que nous
constatons pour didier laguerre
aujourd'hui l'objectif est de trouver de
l'argent
il travaille avec l'état à la mise en
place de plan pluri annuel de
désendettement de la ville
nous travaillons actuellement avec
l'état sur la rédaction de ce contrat
d'accompagnement sur les différents
éléments qui vont nous permettre de
signer ce contrat vers la rentrée de
septembre octobre 2019 ça veut dire que
nous sommes en train de regarder quels
sont les efforts qu'ils ont déjà été
faits par la vue le fond de france en
matière de maîtrise de ses dépenses de
l'amélioration de sa gestion en matière
de d'optimisation aussi de 0,7
une situation financière de ford france
qui a un moins de noms des municipales
l'isq de faire les choux gras de la
campagne et on retrouve le maire de fort
de france didier laguerre bonsoir
bonsoir vous avez voté donc un budget en
déséquilibre de 36 millions d'euros ça
veut dire qu'il faudra faire l'impasse
sur un certain nombre de travaux et de
réalisation dans quels secteurs allez
vous effectuer des coupes
nous avons voté un budget en
déséquilibre
6 millions d'euros à mettre en relation
avec les 55 millions huit cent soixante
cinq mille annoncé par nationale des
côtes en janvier avec l'essai comme 3
millions de l'arrêté préfectoral notre
grille qui a tranché m 53 millions et
des poussières
notre objectif elle à la fois de
pratiquer la transparence des chiffres
et des éléments c'est ce que je fais
lors des séances du conseil municipal
c'est aussi ce que je fais avec nos
différents partenaires de l'état mais
c'est aussi de poursuivre le travail qui
a été initiée sur la ville de
fort-de-france et le fait que le budget
soit déséquilibré de 53 millions d'euros
d'après arrêté préfectoral pour 2018 ne
nous a pas empêchés de mettre en oeuvre
des politiques publiques à la fois en
matière au recueillement sera touchée à
l'info en matière scolaire à la fois en
termes d'aménagement ça ne remet pas en
cause les lives des investissements qui
sont à réaliser sur le territoire de la
ville simplement nous sommes en train de
débattre et de discuter avec les
différents ministères concernés
un plan d'accompagnement de la ville
nous permet enfin à la fois de retourner
à l'équilibré budgétaire mais également
de poursuivre les investissements qui
sont nécessaires sur le la ville de fort
de france pense à l'hameçon plus que
vous en parlez de ce plan
d'accompagnement contrat
d'accompagnement qui serait assigné donc
à la rentrée
comment ça va se passer qui qui
finalement va injecter de l'argent alors
comment ça va se passer
on continue à travailler sur la maîtrise
des dépenses de la ville dépense de
fonctionnement sur les différents postes
de dépenses on continue à travailler
également sur la diversification des
recettes sur des engagements de
d'amélioration de la gestion pris par la
ville mais aussi sur des gosses y est
exceptionnelle de la ville devront
continue également à travailler sur la
structure même des recettes de la ville
puisque le groupe de travail mis en
place à ma demande au comité des
finances locales droit produire ses
conclusions dans le cadre de la
préparation du projet de loi de finances
2010 c'est à dire avant les grandes
vacances
tout ça doit nous permettre à la fois
d'avoir de la visibilité sur les
investissements qui vont être réalisés
la semaine dernière j'étais encore à
paris pour discuter de ces questions là
notamment avec le ministère de la
cohésion des territoires et ce plan
d'accompagnement doit prendre en compte
les nécessaires investissements qui
doivent avoir lieu sur le territoire
devront donc falloir élargir les
recettes
où trouver de nouvelles recettes
naturellement de foyalais pensent à leur
feuille d'impôts est ce que la fed
impôts risque
augmenter non pas du tout la feuille
d'automne pas d'augmenter parce que nous
avons déjà le niveau d'imposition qui
est élevé et donc il serait
contreproductif d'augmenter les impôts
en espèces peut y avoir des recettes
supplémentaires par an contre il faut
diversifier les voies 7 il faut par
exemple dans le cadre des délégations de
service public que nous avons fait en
sorte que ces délégations de service
public sur les parkings de la jso ni par
grappes ont de l'argent à la ville de
france n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
si ce n'était pas le cas sur la joyau
les équipements le crématorium de la
joyau nous avons commencé possible parce
que les délégations de service public
ont été passées dans les années 90 dans
ces conditions là avec des
multinationales qui ont imposé que la
ville viennent équilibrer avec le pays
avec des déficits d'exploitation que
vous vous portez apple a répondu que
j'assume
j'assume l'histoire j'assume la
construction de cette ville je suis les
contrats qui ont été passés simplement
aujourd'hui je renégocie ses contrats ça
a été le cas pour la joyau aujourd'hui
nous percevons une recette sur les
salons funéraires
mais aussi sur la crémation et demain
nous percevrons une recette sur les
parkings qui rapporte de l'argent aux
exploitants et qu'il n'est pas reversé à
la ville de fort-de-france
contractuellement nous allons continuer
aussi à diversifier nos sources est met
en place des produits touristiques nous
permettant de tirer un revenu de la
fréquentation touristique parce que nous
portons c'est charles de son qualité
mais nous n'avons pas les voix cette
crise a été posée au comité des finances
locales de façon à évaluer
c'est charles dussault qualité et avoir
des recettes en france on a parlé du
budget en déséquilibre il ya aussi le
compte administratif en déficit et
rock'n nuance entre 10 l'équilibré des
déficits déficit de 22 millions d'euros
ça va forcément interpellé la chambre
régionale
des comptes qui avait demandé vous le
savez donc au préfet de régler le
dossier c'est d'intervenir
l'opposition parle déjà de mise sous
tutelle est ce que ce n'est pas ce qui
vous pend au nez
le fond du problème n'est pas de savoir
si la ville il sera et où sera sous
tutelle aujourd'hui le conseil municipal
a été le compte administratif et le
budget primitif 2010 9 ce qui montre
bien que le conseil municipal a le
pouvoir budgétaire
la chambre avait demandé au préfet
d'arrêter le budget 2010 8 le compte
administratif découlent